actually
[Music]
yeah that's what I want to know huh well
you played around with swords and stuff
yes
[Music]
this my name is freakazoid
and this is my story and I'm freakazoids
daddy we're also going to have blue
lipstick what are you up to nothing one
parently not either so now I'm gonna
have to gasp a fourteen-year-old boy cuz
it's just that kind of day you know
let's do once we be walking without the
master you have nice vibrato going on
right there so this will be friends and
angry awkward over week fourteen your
own boy really really that's the one you
run with just get out of it I mean how
specific was that just act just do it
[Music]
okay well because it's green screen we
can probably just do
[Music]
okay let's see let's see if this will
fly for Doug okay
God you like a multicolored your paint
that's creepy
isn't it yes I mean it's awesome I think
you'll like it
[Laughter]
oh man around the Vegas around there
that's really really oh oh I like
talking to red yeah that's a good yeah
you probably should be doing yeah I say
uh now the deal is if you touch his face
it goes bad so we we have to remake
another it stays moist okay you can't be
touching them okay is there just a boy a
boy so you can't beat specimen Holmes I
get because you were amazing in hunt for
the wilderkin you and Samael deserve an
Oscar I'm sorry have you ever seen a
movie by any of them yes
my jokes hey what we say I'm the only
fourth wall breaking remember why is
that so you can want to be me when you
sneak into these smells here we have Rob
and here we have horny devil cable
border but now before you lost your
family was this when I get them back is
course Teddy I need to clutch
I need my teddy never see him again
no it's apocalyptic future what
yeah yeah yeah I don't know I was like
really cuz I totally would have gone
back it's like I love to have a happy
ending but you know what I really the
sex forces are gonna bear the next man
so I'll take all right yes I'll take
just like I want in on this please
please you make everything good that guy
is amazing I'm starting to think I have
a man crush on this dude because like
I'm just guys like yeah everything may
be a javo boner or a Campbell boner how
dare you my name thank you disabled his
boner here we have Jim Jarrah's he is
our official Ryan Reynolds looking good
feeling good yeah the mask it's it's
made of a latex in yeah I've had a deal
with latex masks
oh yeah like how do you breathe in that
pain there's no the only I didn't
arguably work yeah that's probably worse
than the Darth Vader mask at least I had
like some kind of yeah but that it's
just like airtight yeah traps it in
there so yeah right
quite a bargain okay that's good it
looks like a biker it does loose the
essence Natalie yeah isn't that the idea
behind us I'm not sure who knows it's an
assassin it does it really does
time to find your mask
[Applause]
Tamara's looking good in this shot did
you get the full Brad Pitt face we
needed for that practical effect they
just like use an a-list actors a
throwaway character yeah you're probably
gonna need to change that battery Willy
one two three I totally was gonna die I
put my life on the line to save my
family but they seemed okay yeah I'm
sure they'll continue to be okay an
apocalyptic future why the hell not
yeah we all just do it yeah yeah oh oh
yeah I'm the button that's right do you
have the beer yeah beat your bear for
those the unbearable future future the
unbearable there's no bearings yes I
just saved my little dad jokes
[Laughter]
yeah yeah and now we're going to start X
my family saved yep okay
this isn't that good
Ashwin a stocks
[Laughter]
good yeah okay okay okay yeah this one
we can just wrap whoever wants to say
give it like five seconds I think you
should always be good with you know this
is a very good though yeah
okay so I'll still miss you with us yeah
yeah and then people can just say
whatever they want it to that everybody
this isn't that good yeah journalist
that shawarma kind tastes like the
inside of a bedroom oh you've never been
kandi knows why am I the normal one here
twin fight in front of him
I like the sound effects yeah that's
what I want to know huh you played
around with swords and stuff trust Jim
around swords
he'll slice and dice
[Laughter]
running gun all right you know what
Malcolm I do have you here we're kind of
doing these I'm gonna get and we don't
need the make up super plan of escape
which by its like okay yeah I'll do it
Freddie your darkness I need to go get
my other glove terrible yeah laugh
camera we found a weakness what is this
okay you know what just work me we all
know what's coming
[Music]
still good here good yep cool good
Deadpool does the chase sequence and he
doesn't these all the cars and they run
into a unicorn that then makes them
unicorns oh this is it it's like he
takes over the chasey pretty much oh
okay a little stab in the eye builds
character 90s fashion month 90s or 80s
fashion Gozer
you went there she does not need to
return to our most convenient parallel
dimension okay I'm getting adjusted yeah
I know Gozer I was watching that film
since I was a kid
she's now look like okay okay rolling
now let's make up
hey Betty and act now let's make up for
the dark thing it's movie that we all
know was gonna suck good yeah Malcolm's
kind of scared yeah the katana yeah do
that in the Malcolm come a little bit
more towards ya
yes there you go yeah perfect okay well
we'll do one more from let's make up for
the dark hey ready and action
now let's make up with that dark thing
that we all know is gonna suck
how's my face mm-hmm all right and it's
a close-up mainly above two of them
which to Jim and yep okay
Soviet Russia a fourth won't race to you
you know no knock it off Don Cheadle's
Captain Planet rolling hey ready
[Music]
it's like cockney right hates my friend
I made a promise passed away even though
in the beginning I was practically
tucking you in there to bat jammies
cells when you should become too Batman
the cameras in the movie trailers to you
[Music]
know who's responsible for this we'll
try another one
this is the light each other comfortable
silence just do like five or six
different the wounds oh wow that is a
WoW I mean you already like BAM shut
through the heart and some random
gangster I only 2 seconds in between
okay try three different just whatever
weird set doing the thing about just
weird sound comes out your mouth yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Chinese then take Chinese I like white
people make it just make sure we're not
so what we did yeah so in Chinese boom
we - more so that's General Tso's
chicken salads are the pita we're cuz
we're geniuses
we found the magic combination is it
good I can pretend
you